[Music]
I'm just not that good with people
there is one thing I'm good at was to
find out what they knew but that's kind
of difficult now that you killed
everyone I just don't think you're cut
out for the intelligence this is your
last shot oh my god you have jelly all
over your face I'm definitely posting
that on insta is it too late to
homeschool me are you CIA dreamy
if Kim finds out we got made by a nine
year old my career is over what's the
option kill her make it look like an
accident
maybe the stairs what Wow still
recording we can cut a deal I want you
to teach me how to be a spy just to be
clear this is a one-time arrangement
never again shooting range Ops forces
try to walk away from the explosion a
lie detector test I can smell a lie
endorphins released an odor and the
ultimate tell slightest blink of an eye
I admire all of your tattoos
[Applause]
JJ I believe he is that you've never
taken steroids damn she's good then you
look out there what do you see ninety
civilians minimal security software
meter smiling people having fun you
should try it sometime
[Music]
Marty
[Applause]
the objective of this exercise is to get
past me a good idea might be to cause
the distraction because otherwise
there'd be zero chance of you
[Music]
you're nice time
what is he doing this looks like the
wedding at the end of Shrek
[Music]